З одного боку - самопроголошена ДНР.
З іншого - Росія, колись мирний, а нині агресивний сусід.
Навколо Азовське море, де збільшується військова присутність.
Війна ніби взяла у кільце Маріуполь і не відпускає його жителів.
Багато хто тут не знає, що Київ хоче чітко закріпити у Конституції курс на ЄС і НАТО.
Це район Східний, який був обстріляний у січні 2015-го.
Його мешканець Вадим не впевнений, що війна,
яка лише в кількох кілометрах від його будинку, знову не повернеться.
Допоки гроші є, доти вона, ймовірно, і буде тривати.
Тож, закріплення в Конституції курсу України на ЄС і НАТО може і не допомогти.
Так або ще більш категорично у цьому житловому масиві Маріуполя,
який відновлювали після обстрілів багато благодійних міжнародних організацій,
вважає не лише один Вадим.
Це нам вже набридло! Я проти!
Навіщо це нам?
Ви зробіть спершу, щоб в нас було добре! Щоб  вони до нас захотіли, а не ми до них.
В жодному разі ні! Яке НАТО?
Від кого нас захищати з цим НАТО?
Щоб зайві гроші платити державі за НАТО?
Допоки ми самі собі не допоможемо, нам ніщо не допоможе. Ні ЄС, ні НАТО.
У Маріуполі дуже рідко чути українську мову. Превалює російська.
Тут ще багато людей через інтернет дивляться російське телебачення
і відповідно переймають те саме радянське кліше про загрозу "чобота НАТО,
який буде топтати нашу землю" чи-то деякі нові меседжі з Москви,
що в ЄС українцям буде менше роботи.
Їх ставлення до Євросоюзу і НАТО чітко пов'язано з тим, кого вони підтримують у війні,
яка триває поряд з ними, або до якої політичної сили належать ще з довоєнних часів.
Частина суспільства, яке, ну скажімо так, не визначилася щодо сторони конфлікту,
в нього така позиція: лише б війни не було.
А щодо ЄС і НАТО в неї теж така невизначена позиція.
І я вважаю, що тут треба відокремити категорію не за віковим критерієм.
Я думаю, що за критерієм освіти.
Відповіді на тему ЄС і НАТО у місті металургів і моряків,
а нині ще й військових, дуже залежать ще і від району проживання.
У центрі міста, де триває активна реконструкція будинків,
ремонт доріг або в зоні відпочинку - думки більш позитивні.
Я за Угоду, за співробітництво з ЄС.
НАТО? Треба тільки проводити референдум.
Така позиція невпевнена… завершиться правління Путіна, і все буде мирно.
Можливо, це і є наш шлях у майбутньому. Але це ж не зараз.
Це довгий процес становлення, розвитку.
Треба рухатися вперед. Тому що ми самі? Ну, куди?
Ми нікуди не рухаємося, стоїмо на місці.
Ми залишилися на рівні СРСР, від нього треба йти.
Євростандарти в укладанні пішохідної плитки.
Присутність слова "євро" у назвах, хай навіть того ж ломбарду.
Насправді, Євросоюз набагато ближчий до жителів Маріуполя, ніж вони можуть собі це уявити.
Постійна присутність міжнародних місій ще з початку війни.
Велика консультативна та, головне, фінансова допомога від партнерів по ЄС і НАТО.
Це не один мільйон євро, які пішли на різні міські інфраструктурні проекти
або на допомогу переселенцям, які стали мешканцями Маріуполя.
Для них побудований не лише цей гуртожиток,
в планах мерії - перший в Україні спільний з ФРН проект придбання житла на вторинному ринку.
В мерії Маріуполя розуміють, що багатьом мешканцям,
коли поруч війна, складно з цього радіти.
Ті, хто хочуть  це бачити, вони це бачать.
Ті, які принципово не хочуть це помічати, вони це помітять, але промовчать.
Ми змушені наразі розвиватися з більшою силою,
тому що ми на цих територіях маємо показати тим територіям, що тут краще.
Більшість чиновників мерії - у віці до 45-ка. Вони прагнуть великого переформатування Маріуполя.
Їхній хештег: "Тут варто жити".
Маріуполь треба більше інформувати про сенс стратегічних рішень Києва, вважають тут.
Наразі інформацію про ЄС і в меншій мірі про НАТО
можна знайти в єдиному інфоцентрі в держуніверситеті.
Зрештою, місто на березі моря свій шлях в Європу чітко визначило ще в 2010-му році,
коли посли країн ЄС відкрили цей пам'ятний знак.
Маленький євросквер може стати великим європарком.
З такими от символічними зірками ЄС посередині великого фонтану.